I had to pick like five favorite movies
of the year and a lot of people agree
with me Grand Budapest Hotel fantastic
absolutely fantastic
[Applause]
thank you very much uh and I'm just what
was working on because I had so many
great cameos so many stars of such high
caliber it must have been fun making
that movie well it's amazing the way uh
you know Ray finds is in it Jeff
Goldblum Jude Law right Tilda Swinton
incredible people
um and the way Wes Anderson makes movies
is it's a beautiful thing he actually
has everyone live together in one space
okay so we live all in one hotel he gets
a small hotel and all the actors live
together and because of that you can
have all these kind of strange
unexpected things happen like have lunch
with people I had lunch with Jeff I had
soup with Jeff Goldblum for maybe eight
hours which I don't know how that's
possible but um but I love Jeff Goldberg
I don't want to have soup with him for
eight hours it was a long time but then
I don't now I feel like I don't have to
have soup with them for a while oh my
God I had enough soup that it's like uh
do you want to get together no I don't I
don't feel obligated to do that anymore
I'm good but I love it but it's all hard
I get nervous around famous people you
know I really do I I'm I respect you
both I'm very nervous just about to say
you're safe here
thank you but I feel I want to do a good
job for you no uh Bill Murray I mean
you're running out with Bill Murray on
that film yeah Bill Murray I feel you
know like uh Bill I've known since I was
17 years old I met him on the on the
movie Rushmore yeah which is my first
movie thank you so yes yeah yeah and um
they're showing a lot of respect there
no it was very nice just a brilliant
movie yeah well I uh I was so nervous to
meet him because he's a Ghostbuster and
uh I grew up loving the Ghostbusters it
was funny that a kid your age would
think of him when you meet him at 17 as
a go I would not see him and say oh wow
you're a Ghostbuster I would think about
the star not live from the 70s I'm a
different generation well it's true you
know his growing up in I was born in
1980 so my he was in all of those big
movies for me but at the the Saturday
Night Live stuff came later for me but
yeah I mean he used to go that's Peter
Venkman that Doctor Peter Venkman and um
but uh I was very nervous and I I think
that I go about being nervous a weird
way because they become overly
affectionate like apparently he says to
this day that when I first met him I
tried to hug him and he sideswiped me
um and then I fell he didn't move to the
side but it was I've also gotten you
know I worked with Steve Martin too
who's another one of my heroes and um
and that was probably the worst case of
being Starstruck which is that I was in
a movie shop girl that he made yeah and
um part of it thank you thank you great
movie and uh part of the uh process was
that he I had to meet with him and you
know he wrote it so he he got to choose
the final person uh and I and I was so
scared on the way over there driving
driving just thinking if he doesn't like
you it's not it's not my fault right
it's his fault that he doesn't like me
right it's not you it's him right and on
the way over there I was just saying
just relax just relax but the main thing
I was worried about was bringing up the
movie Three Amigos right because to me
that's a movie I quote more than any
other movie maybe right um
you didn't want to bring it up because
it would make you seem like too much of
a geeky yeah I wanted to try to come to
him
artist to artist right uh but I or just
not put a lot of pressure on him you
know but I walk into this hotel and I'm
just thinking don't say and don't say it
don't say it don't say it and um I'm
looking around then there he is he
stands up he's got a sparkling water he
waves to me I walk over Hello nice to
meet you hello Mr Martin it's pleasure
to meet you before we sit down I just
want to say Three Amigos changed my life
and
he says I see and we're still standing
kind of crouched like half standing up
and I said that scene where you eat the
bat by the fire because of that I've
always wanted to eat a bat
um and it was a very awkward meeting and
yeah but yeah then it's you know what
it's something to do then then it's time
to go in for a hug real fast go hard go
hard for the hug go fast before he can
side go to the body go to the body